Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new spider-man 3 marvel
video Tom Holland was giving us all
kinds of information and details about
what's going on with the movie the venom
crossover in Marvel's sinister six movie
that they're getting ready to do there's
even a brand new spider-man spin-off
movie that they're developing that I'll
talk about there's a bunch of Easter
eggs also explain what's going on with
all the delays that just got announced
there's a bunch of movies and TV shows
that were delayed this week because of
all the craziness if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos I will keep doing updates as
things change the next couple of weeks
it might get a little crazy in the next
couple of weeks but it's not quite as
bad as it seems I was doing a movie
ticket giveaway but because of all the
theater closings and cancelations will
turn that into an Amazon giveaway for
now all you have to do to enter that
it'd just be a subscriber and leave all
your theories about spider-man 3 on the
video so we'll just break this down top
5 style starting with number 5 Tom
Holland is still out promoting his new
Pixar movie with star-lord Chris Pratt
they released the movie before everyone
started delaying their movies so of
course it's still out in theaters they
still have to promote it
of course everyone doing interviews is
asking him spider-man questions so
that's where all this spider-man 3 venom
crossover sinister 6 stuff comes from in
the spider-man spin-off movie the really
good news is that Tom Holland said that
spider-man 3 has not been delayed
they're still filming the movie starting
in July it's on the same schedule as
they were for the production of
spider-man far from home Tom Holland
even talked about the story the script
obviously the big sinister six
characters that were coming back in some
form thankfully marvel's snipers did not
take him out on the spot and when I say
sinister six characters appearing during
spider-man 3 technically all the
spider-man Marvel movies have always had
characters who were part of the comic
book Sinister 6 team like vulture
scorpion Mysterio during spider-man far
from home but Marvel and Sony only
started specifically talking about their
sinister six plans and venom
crossover plans recently.
Marvel Studios is excited
to show you what comes next.
You're going to love this.
These villains that we now have in our
universe happen to be characters that
are in the sinister six.
There may be something that happens with that.
No matter where he goes
the world is going to  be
different for him.
here's the real blockbuster
brace yourselves you might want to sit
down.
Spider-Man's name is Peter Parker!
What the?!
no more hiding
yeah no more hiding
There's a difference in doing sinister six
Easter eggs and references to
spider-man comic book moments then
coming right out and saying yes we are
definitely going to make a sinister six
movie with these characters that you
keep seeing in all these movies number
four when Tom Holland was talking about
the story and the script for spider-man
3 he said it was a way bigger movie than
spider-man far from home so they just
keep getting bigger and bigger with the
movies pretty standard fare even though
spider-man is going to be on the run
John wick 3style from everyone hunting
him Jay jonah Jameson The Daily Bugle
dotnet putting him on blast all the
different sinister six characters that
are coming back Thunderbolt Ross the
world security council in the US
government right now they're still only
going to be one real big main villain
though which is tradition with the MCU
spider-man movies that's the big
difference in the modern era spider-man
from Andrew Garfield and Tobey Maguire
spider-man but they're going to be cameos
and references to all the future venom
crossover in sinister six movies and
spider-man 4 yes there is a spider-man 4
that Sony is planning on making with Tom
Holland recently I also just did a video
about Sony confirming that they are
planning on reciting the sharing deal
with Marvel so spider-man 4 will also be
a Marvel movie but obviously they
haven't resigned the deal yet that won't
happen till after they get done making
spider-man 3 in another big spider-man
crossover movie and while Tom Holland
was talking about all the spider-man 3
stuff he interestingly revealed that he
doesn't know what the big crossover
movie that he's going to be doing it
Marvel is going to be that's going to
happen after spider-man 3 before
spider-man 4 we're at the point with Tom
Holland now where Marvel knows that he's
going to leak anything that they give
him so they just wait to tell him things
until they want it to be leaked.
Oooh, goodness.
my favorite one probably carnage one day.
Carnage?
he's so coo
And what about Venom?
Like a transition into the Venom
Are you trying to get a scoop out of me?
maybe?
I'm not yeah I'm
not involved in that at all.
I actually...
oh no I can't say that
whoops
Thankfully Marvel is not pulling a Tobey
Maguire spider-man 3 with their
spider-man 3 or an Andrew Garfield
amazing spider-man 2 situation what
happened during those movies as you all
remember is that Sony when they were
making them on their own were so thirsty
to set up sequels and spin-offs that
they crammed way too many villains into
each movie and hijacked the core
spider-man's story of each of those
movies spending way too much time doing
full-blown origin stories for all the
different villains and side characters
when the big Sony hack happened a couple
of years ago it revealed some of Kevin
Feige
advice that he gave to the Sony people
when they were making amazing spider-man
to one of his biggest pieces of advice
to them was that he told them that they
didn't need to do full-blown origin
stories for each of the villains inside
amazing spider-man 2 but you can save
this for another movie you don't need to
give this character all these other
scenes and backstory
that's why Marvel's been taking it so
slow with the sinister six set up stuff
in the Tom Hollands spider-man movies in
the actual spider-man venom crossover
it's been four years since Tom hoenn
started playing spider-man it really
just starting to hear about their plans
for big venom crossover and sinister six
stuff we won't even see those movies for
a couple more years
speaking of which number three Sony just
announced a new live-action spider-man
spin-off movie a big spider-man spin-off
movie Roberto Orci who had previously
worked for Sony on their main spider-man
movies before they rebooted the
franchise with Tom Holland and Marvel in
the MCU is working on their new big
spider-man spin-off movie since its Sony
that made the announcement they're
developing it not Marvel the top picks
for what that spin-off movie are going
to be or an actual spider-man verse the
sinister six movie Roberto Orci is
actually a pretty big name in Hollywood
so he wouldn't do like a really small
tiny film whatever this is going to be
it's going to be a big spider-man movie
the other top picks are big spin-off
movies for new sinister six characters
like Norman Osborn
Green Goblin or dr. octopus because dr.
octopus is OG sinister six and we don't
have a version of him anywhere in the
Sony venom verse or the Marvel MCU yet
or he could also be working on their
full-blown spider-man vs. venom movie
they just announced they started
development on it right now the delays
aren't affecting it so it will probably
be released around 2022 or 2023 just
depending on how long it takes to finish
the first script Sony cranks out their
spider-man movies in their venom movies
way faster than Marvel does so everyone
just post your theories in the comments
about what you think the new big
spider-man spin-off movie is going to be
number two because of the big updated
Marvel Sony sharing deal with spider-man
Marvel also just announced that Tom
Holland is going to be filming a bunch of
new MCU spider-man stuff for their new
avengers campus events if you don't know
what that is that's a big thing for
people traveling to Disneyland Disney
World they film a bunch of new MCU
material and turn it into a big event
series within the MCU
but you physically have to travel there
to experience it all the movies and the
little eclipses and stuff that they film
that only happens at Disneyland and
Disney World
they're going to have a bunch of new
spider-man suits they're going to debut a
bunch of new Robert Downey jr. Ironman
stuff with new Iron Man suits a bunch of
new Doctor Strange stuff so if you're a
big fan of going to those live events
and things like that there's going to be a
bunch of new canon MCU stuff happening
during that it won't get started till
the end of July around the time that
they released the Morbius movie after
comic-con and currently none of the
delays are affecting any of that stuff
the only stuff is being delayed in
Hollywood the big movies TV shows is
stuff that's happening right now
anything that's happening during the
summer or later is probably going to be
fine so number one the current state of
the full-blown spider-man venom
crossover movie is that it's still a
couple years off but as you saw during
the Morbius trailer and we'll see when
we get the venom 2 trailer soon there's
still a lot of spider-man stuff
happening inside the venom verse
spin-off movies
spider-man images and references showing
up side characters like the vulture
having full-blown cameos it's going to be
like that for the next couple of movies
that involve spider-man and spider-man
related characters like venom Morbius
the other sinister six characters the
only reason why they haven't
the venom 2 trailer right now just
because of all the craziness right now
and because the bloodshot movie just is
not doing well critically or at the box
office they're also using this extra
time to polish the special effects on
venom and carnage before they actually
start showing people footage they're
using venom 2 as a little bit of a soft
reboot of the franchise just because
they ran into some production issues on
the first movie and it was before they'd
figured out what they were going to do with
Tom Hollands spider-man
in future venom movies now that that's
all figured out they can have way more
fun so just expect that first venom 2
trailer in the next four weeks or so
depending on how crazy stuff gets the
next couple of weeks as of right now in
terms of delays and cancelations Black
Widow has not been delayed it's still
coming out at the beginning of May but
if they do wind up delaying it it'll
probably come out in July because it
sets up a lot of stuff that goes on
during Falcon and Winter Soldier and
Marvel phase 4 so they can't release
Black Widow after they released the
Marvel phase 4 series and eternals is
still coming out of November that also
has to happen after Black Widow but I
will do update videos if we get more
delays on stuff so don't worry about too
much of that right now
but everyone click here for that brand
new Marvel Falcon in Winter Soldier
teaser video and click here for the new
the boys season 2 trailer video
thank you so much
for watching. Everyone stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!